yes i think that way
the roads are still a bit unfamiliar but
watford is where they call home i like
watford i would like to stay in work for
if i have this chance
fareed who worked for the british
embassy in kabul as a translator was
evacuated last summer along with the
family of his passenger also called
fareed between them they have 12
children and they've all spent the last
year in a hotel
living in the hotel is really hard so
hotels or only to spend holidays not for
living
it's not the hotel itself fareed is
complaining about but the inability to
set up home and move on with their lives
in so many other ways they're putting
down roots their children are in school
and they've been warmly welcomed by the
local community
but for evacuees around the country
finding enough suitable affordable
housing where they want to settle is
proving difficult
it's all the stuff that is more like
routine life now so it has changed a lot
over the year from that just being
welcoming to now we better help you live
because you are going to be here for
some time
britain has a desperate shortage of
social housing with a million people on
the waiting list
there are nine and a half thousand
afghan evacuees still in bridging hotels
it's unclear how many of them have been
made an offer of accommodation but we've
learned the home office is taking a
tougher stance against those who turn
down what they've been given
in a newsletter written for afghan
evacuees living in hotels seen by sky
news the home office says it will make a
maximum of two offers it says if they
declined both offers without good
reasons they'll not make any further
offers
and it warns evacuees will have to then
leave the hotel and make their own
arrangements for
accommodation kris kandaya works with
the government as an unpaid advisor on
refugees and asylum seekers
it's not appropriate for us
to use threatening language to say look
if you don't do what you're told you're
going to be punished i think that's a
really bad
tonality and it's not treating people
with the dignity they deserve
bashir is amongst the 7 000 afghan
evacuees who've been provided with
housing but although he's struggling
with the cost of living in central
london says afghans should be prepared
to move
probably you won't find your ideal place
you know through
through a scheme that supports you you
know your ideal place needs to be
created by yourself you know by your
determination by your whole hard work
the home office says it's trying to move
people as quickly as possible and hotels
whilst not a long-term solution offer
safe secure accommodation for afghan
evacuees as they try to rebuild their
lives lisa holland sky news